that's the plot of that the horror movie
version of jack frost also
yeah my favorite movie that i think i've
talked about way too many times on the
show oh my god what in
[Laughter]
what body part is the gear supposed to
be
it's all it's doesn't matter let's not
put too much thought into it there you
go
hey today we are going to talk about
terrible tv shows that should never be
rebooted tom
what is a terrible tv show hi what's a
terrible tv show that you think should
not be rebooted
i'm glad you asked brian i was looking
at the uh at the uh
the article that we have about this very
subject up on looper.com
thank you nina and uh
number one with a bullet on there uh
manimal i don't know if you guys
remember man who here remembers your
animal well nina you're 12. what's that
vaguely
vaguely aware that manimal existed i
mean you say who remembers mannable
manimal it says it was on in 1983. i am
pretty sure you weren't born yet
i mean there's no way of knowing i'm a
timeless beauty but
an animal
1983. tom has always been here and tom
will always be here i'd like to think
you're right about that
there's something
more about me
manimal
if you get a chance
go check out manimal it's not good so uh
the the the concept what we have here is
a uh a guy
a uh a white guy
who uh
because he he learns how to turn into
different animals a man
because
because of a man if you will uh
brian will
and he learns how to do this thanks
because because africa
oh no yeah he's in africa
and then he isn't in africa and because
africa happened to him uh so some big
magic happened and now he can turn into
an animal
does
the song africa by toto factor into this
show in any way shape or form because
it's the only way i would be interested
okay if it did that would improve it
yeah i would watch it if the whole show
was just like
that song playing over and over again a
22-minute music video with a new
you might talk to nbc about like
changing their lineup for uh prime time
this fall because if perfect that's
actually i will give
the worst thing put the put the head of
nbc's name right down here a call
we're doing terrific
animal faith uh
what's interesting but so like not good
only lasted eight episodes uh uh
real drag what's interesting about it is
the uh stan winston who generally
speaking can do no wrong uh
or okay he passed away he uh did the the
special effects for the
man turning into immo
uh
segment
he did a uh there's a segment where the
uh the main character turns into a
panther and a segment where he turns
into a hawk
and uh
they're hit and miss
they're okay there's like there's a
couple of shots that are very like
american werewolf in london and then
like
and then there'll be just one shot of
what appears to be like a taxidermied
nice panther paw with with just like
plastic claws getting pushed through the
end of it it's uh
it's not great it's not great so they
would like blow their budget on one
scene and be like
that's it folks like the rest of it very
much appeared dude
yeah because he turned into other
animals and you just
you never really saw that part that that
was left to your imagination it's like
look stock footage of a cheetah i mean
animal yeah
did they ever say he turned into an
animal on screen
like someone's like oh he turned into a
bird but it's like you can't it's not
even on in the shop 100 yeah it turns
into snakes and stuff and like that's
just sort of left to your imagination
which is wouldn't it be great though if
if like yeah i think that what nina's
getting at though is like wouldn't it be
great if the transformation scene 100
still happen but with people just
watching like
that's what i'm that's exactly what i
meant is like it's just reaction shots
for other people it's incredible he's
turning into a snake whoa this is the
craziest thing i've ever seen i think
under my direction we should maybe
reboot manimal this is a perfect i think
what if we rebooted it and called it
womanimal
it's interesting that you bring that up
because a couple years after it was
canceled
uh
the creator of the show
brought the character back in another
show that i want to say it was called
nina you
you're not going to believe me here but
i think the show was called night man
i don't believe you
[Laughter]
i'm gonna look this up real quick did he
ever fight the day man
maybe do karate kicks across the stage a
planned episode for season two
did he have cat eyes
he hit the point asking all the right
questions
you're doing a perfect job
thank you
i'm sorry you can't say the word
nightman and expect me to not like
already have the always sunny song stuck
in my head hang on a second totally fine
lodged in my baby this actor the actor
who played manimal was named simon
mccorkandale
i'm sorry i mean that's from a courtney
that's a funny name i buried the lead on
that one
simon mccorkandale
i hope that's a stage name because
that's a great name to choose that's all
not that i think it's an unfortunate
name i think it's just a very exciting
name i wish my name was fun to say
brian mccorkandale you can change it
i could so thank you a full 14 years
after the show after manimal went off
the air they brought the character back
trying to give him a backdoor pilot for
his daughter to become the new manimal
uh on a program called night man that
also didn't last very long wow back to
our pilot on a flop
these are fact
yeah pretty cool
all right
so that's manimal i guess yeah yeah you
bet it is nina what do you think i was
gonna say my pick's a little similar it
is not minimal but i'm gonna lead into
it by talking about
uh the concept of like taking a a
commercial or a very short bit and
making it into a tv series oh no so
no no no no ted lasso did that right and
i'm going to use movies and earnest and
the earnest movies but that's movies i'm
talking about
oh my god i forgot about max headroom
see i'm getting so there's a few
there's a few but i mean i would say ted
lasso is like an unnervingly good
example of it and that ted lasso is a
good show populated with like
well-written characters and it's really
like you can't believe that like a bit
jason sudeikis probably came up with in
five minutes
is like out there winning emmys i mean
that dude probably came up with that
like
off the cuff at espn headquarters or
whatever that's like if the coneheads
movie was nominated for several oscars
right it's crazy that that's how the
origin of this like deeply emotional
like
like
gut-wrenching but also hilarious show
but i'm not here to talk about ted lasse
because that's a great show and i love
it i'm here to talk about
i'm here to talk about the opposite of
what happens when you take a commercial
that already sucks and you make it suck
a lot harder and that is uh the series
cavemen which was based
starring nick kroll starring nick kroll
yes and i i remembered like i didn't
watch this show when it was on because
why would i have done that
so i watched
seven minutes of the first episode today
and very good cause
physical pain it's so deeply unfunny so
first of all the prosthetics that they
wear
as the cavemen are so limiting that like
they can't really do anything with their
mouths or faces and they all sound like
they're they're like a big wad of
chewing gum in their mouths but like
it's just sitting there
well yeah it's like the ramy malek in
bohemian rhapsody problem where it's
just like the teeth just get in the way
of everything i hate that movie um
but i'm sorry
but yeah so like it premiered
oh my god i didn't even look at the
dates before this it only aired from
october to november of 2007.
it made it one
month
and also to just back up real fast the
commercials that these were from was a
it was a geico commercial
and it was it was a it was a guy who
looked like a caveman on an automated
sidewalk at an airport and then he
passes a billboard that says saving
money with geico is so easy even a
caveman could do it and then he looks
upset and everyone
it was like caveman cavemania is what
right and then geico like i don't know
geico has too many this is not i'm not
the first person to make this
observation way too many mascots like
pick one
you can't have caveman and a gecko
and like i feel like there's a million
other things that i can't even think of
right now but
a little money with the eyes on it
[Music]
thanks for
making sure i don't sleep tonight
where's that tv show
so caveman was a bad show i think we all
know that like it also i didn't remember
this happening there was a controversy
over the pilot because it was accused of
using
like cavemen as stand-ins for like
racial inequality
and it was also set in atlanta and it
had some very like unsettling bad
undertones undertones i don't think they
were under
like they were taught i think they were
they were tones pretty much
yeah they moved it to california but i
think they still had southern accents
and so it was like why
why do they have those what this is
super out of context um and so
yeah like uh
it was ruined by critics everybody hated
it it got cancelled almost immediately
um
yeah 13 episodes were produced the final
six never aired so seven aired that's it
ross classic
bad show no it's not though if anyone
rebooted this
they sh they i would
i would personally request that they go
to jail um it would
it would be a crime i think under maybe
the geneva convention to reboot the show
uh i'll have a legal expert check on
that for me
but yeah i mean
this i this felt like a slam dunk pick
to me nobody out there is like wow i
really loved cavemen i mean and the
humor on it too is so like
is bad uh it's
there's all these weird heavy pauses
where no one knows what to do because
the jokes are so clearly unfunny um
it's really weirdly misogynistic like
out of the gate they're just gross about
women
i mean they are neanderthals
yeah but they keep being like but we're
not like one of them is like has a
laptop and is playing solitaire and is
doing his dissertation for his phd so
like the whole joke is that they're not
neanderthals
but it also has this weird like the
intro is like cavemen have always been
here and we always will much like tom
and i was like so are they immortal like
have they been alive this whole time
like this isn't what we do in the
shadows a good show like i just there
are so many conversations that needed to
happen
from from pitch to to
and apparently everybody just went yeah
this is gonna make us bags of money
great go for it yeah
this is gonna sell a lot of insurance
guys i'm guessing a lot of people were
were uh let go from i believe it was abc
after
that it was abc after that it must have
been expensive too because you have to
do all the prosthetics you have to
license it from guys
you do have to license it but i was
going to say the prosthetics don't look
like they cost a whole lot
halloween money
yeah
or like amazon maybe
it was just like a kit
did you get to the part in the first
episode where they realized that maybe
it's the humans who are the uncivilized
ones after all
i think that's the whole joke
yeah
yeah pretty smart stuff nina
you're right i just went over my head
anyway caveman that's my pick it's a bad
show nobody make it again thank you uh
i'm gonna briefly touch on a few from
the looper.com article i'm so mad i
didn't think of caveman because that is
a movie that is a show i actually
you watched it i didn't think anything i
watched the first episode i just mean i
saw it when it happened right you know
who was your favorite character
what
who's your favorite character on caveman
nick
cave man
one i remember being nickel
uh one that's on here brother had a tv
t-shirt that said that nick kroll cave
man i'm gonna cherry pick a few here
we've got facts of life i don't remember
that being terrible but that would be
weird to
reboot like
all these girls in a boarding school in
like 2021 how would i don't know about
that one
isn't it
yeah it's just it's just worse gossip
girl love boat how would love boat in
2021 go right like it would just be a
reality show it would be that cruise
that they wouldn't let doc in march of
2020.
so so like so sort of like what they did
with fantasy island they make it a
horror movie yeah yeah this is the
gritty reboot of love boat yeah
presents
[Laughter]
hate boat
[Laughter]
um perfect my favorite joke is just
saying the opposite of the thing
every time
yeah now alph is another show i remember
from my childhood days
we don't want those
well he eats cats i think that's
problematic i think elf would be
canceled for eating cats
al so out the premise of alf is that it
is that an alien crash lands on earth
into the garage of a normal suburban
family
and for whatever reason instead of
calling the police
or the government they adopt him like a
roommate and it's terrible for the
family like it doesn't go well it's very
annoying and he and as mentioned he
keeps trying to eat their cat um
it's a it was performed by like a puppet
a muppet style puppet so you've got you
know one puppeteer with a hand here and
a hand here and then a a second
puppeteer doing the other hand and
pretty sure and sometimes
when they needed full body shots they
would just stick a kid or a small person
into an elf costume and wasn't there an
episode where he brains he goes on a
blind watching it it was so upsetting
there's there's an episode where he goes
on a blind date with a literal blind
woman
okay because it's the only way that he
could find no that's a 30 rock joke
i'm i'm
fairly certain that this happened it's
also a 30 minute show okay that's
awesome
because kenneth does that yeah
okay oh that's right that's right
other salient points about alf i
remember that his name was gordon
shumway he's from the planet melmac and
there was a cartoon based on alf that i
also watched and he made an appearance
in the cartoon all-stars uh no more
drugs thank you please
that's right he teamed up with garfield
the care bears the muppet babies alvin
and the chipmunks slimer bugs bunny
the regular avengers don't smoke pot
um and it worked
yeah when a bunch of cartoon characters
gather to tell you not to do drugs you
either definitely listen to life or you
definitely don't yeah yeah you're like i
need
something to make this
disappear
things have gone wrong
um
another another another one on here
which i don't think i'm gonna say is a
terrible show because i remember it
fondly but you certainly could not
reboot it today who's the boss where the
premise is
a woman in charge a man who's a nanny
what
and that's the whole premise now you
know back in the 80s
it was fine
it was so zany that a woman might be in
charge of something yeah it was a fine
little move a little show that kind of
you know challenged gender conventions
at the time and you've got a very
charismatic lead and tony danza and all
the rest of the cast judith light uh
other actors whose names i've forgotten
but they're all there too i get it it's
a product of its time i'm not gonna crap
on it for like they were trying
then now it would be like what yeah
you'd be like yeah what's the big deal
that's just that it's just like every
day right it's fine right um but one
that's not on here
that i remember existing during the
course of this conversation was a show
called viper do you remember that has
anyone heard of viper
so you remember knight rider and how the
premise of that was like there's a guy
who does missions with his super smart
car who can talk to you
imagine that but take away the part
where the car can talk that's viper and
also add in licensing from dodge and
their new car the viper
okay and that's it
so it's the opposite of cavemen where
it's a show that is a commercial not a
commercial this is a show correct and
it's just it's just it's just a really
fancy car like i think it like morphs or
something from a regular dodge viper to
the
to the special effect version of the
dodgeball i thought you were gonna i
thought you're gonna say it more from a
regular one to like the one with the
nicer cup holders and the better stereo
system
like three more options yeah it morphs
into the upsell version of the car
could you imagine like
a new version of that show that's like a
different car company it's like pt
cruiser and he goes around solving
grimes in his station wagon
it's actually kind of a good idea that's
not bad that's actually detective pt
cruiser honestly i think we could
distract elon musk from doing a lot of
other stuff if we also offered him a
show called tesla and he just drove
around in a tesla and solved who's the
star we could distract him for a while
yeah he solves crimes by installing
giant batteries in people's garages yeah
that would casually
[Laughter]
so yeah there's that and then i just
thought of another show just just now
called turbo teen do you know turbo teen
all i can think of is turbo team from i
think you should leave but go on no all
right i have to pull this up for you now
was this the uh was this the kid that
could turn into a car
that's correct oh cool so basically the
premise of this show this is a cartoon
from the 80s
where
this kid's driving is convertible right
and uh and he accidentally crashes into
an experiment that's happening somewhere
in a science lab and he gets zapped by
the ray
and now and and then this happens so
just watch this
video unfold
that's the plot of that the horror movie
version of jack frost also
yeah it's my favorite movie that i think
i've talked about way too many times on
the show oh my god what in
what body part is the gear supposed to
be
it's all it's doesn't matter let's not
put too much thought into it there you
go
yeah it's disgusting isn't it it's
really horrific to watch never no i
wouldn't make that that's another crime
straight to jail with you
so yeah that's amazing live action
reboot of that
and really lean into just the body
horror of it yeah
[Applause]
make david lynch do it make david lynch
make this movie and i would watch it
absolutely oh my god no the children's
television
honestly i'd watch the the crap out of
that put the weirdest person in charge
terrible kane the guy who's
origin stories that he lived in philly
for a little while got really weird
i love this
so yeah so those are our picks anyway
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe do you know where curly's gold
is it's in my pocket